字幕: Yuri Ueda
校正: Kazunori Akashi
皆さん こんにちは
皆さん これからの人生
目標をお持ちでしょうか
「目標持ってないよ」と言われる方
ちょっと手を挙げてもらえます？
あ 後の方でちょっと挙がりましたね　はい
手を挙げられなかった方
「持ってるに越したことはないよ」と
お思いでしょうか
いやいや　実は 私
本当に目標が必要なんだろうかと
思っているんですよ
例えば 海外留学したいとか
大きい会社に就職したいとか
そういう目標があるからこそ
辛い勉強も頑張ってできるって
こともあるでしょう
しかし「目標を追いかけることが
全てではない」
と 体験いたしました
それはちょうど私が トランスミッションの
開発に従事してた時のことでした
トランスミッションといいますのはエンジンの
動力をタイヤに伝える重要なものです
日本ではオートマチックがほとんどですが
私の従事してたマニュアル式というのは
手で操作するということから
操る楽しさを追求する人に
根強い人気があります
そのプロジェクトは 高級車にふさわしい―
滑らかで かつ ワクワクするような
操作感を狙って
カーメーカーともいろいろ仕様を
打ち合わせる中で開発を進めておりました
新しい技術も取り入れながら
何度も試作と試験を繰り返し
やっと 目標の達成する
ミッションを作ることができました
しかし カーメーカーから
搭載して走っていると時々引っかかるよ
ということを指摘されました
早速 試験機に取り付けて
いろいろ確認しましたけど
出てきません その現象は
そもそも 高い目標値をクリアしてるんです
そういう問題が出たとしても
そういうものを納入するはずはありません
いわれるように車に搭載して
いろいろなデータをとって解析した結果
車側の要因でその現象が出てくる
ということがわかりました
そこで カーメーカーに対して
車側で対応して欲しい
ということをお願いしました
と同時に ここで私たちがクリアできれば
技術者として新しい発見が
あるんじゃないか という
心が湧いてきました
目標値ではなくて 本当の姿を追いかける
そうすると そこに大きな成長がある
自分自身に大きな成長もみられる と
チャレンジする心が湧いてきました
そこで カーメーカーと一緒になって
各々の領域の中で
いろいろ対策をして
この問題を解決することができました
と同時に 同じ戦った仲間ということで
つながって その後いい関係を
構築することができました
チャレンジする心を大切に
ありたい姿の実現に向かって
努力することによって大きな成果が出る
多くの仲間ができる
それを喜びと感じました
退職した後は その体験をもとに
「興味にチャレンジ　世界を広げる」
ということを私のキーワードにして
自分の住んでいる街 安城を探索しました
その一つが 野菜作り講座でありました
そこはマニュアルが整備されて
先生の指導のもとに
種をまいて 苗を植えて 育てて収穫する
同じようにやっても 同じようにいいものは
なかなかできません
思うようにできないということは
逆に言えば いろいろ試行錯誤していけば
いいものができるという可能性が
高いということじゃありませんか
仕事時代のチャレンジ精神が蘇ってきました
早速 私は農園を借りました
それだけではなくて
野菜作りグループにも入っていきました
その野菜作りグループは
野菜を作っているだけではなくて
市のイベントにも出たり
農家のお手伝いをしたり
子どもを呼んで農業体験もさせたりしました
ちょうど私の
「興味にチャレンジ　世界を広げる」
というキーワードにぴったりの活動です
私はできる限り あちこちに顔を出しました
市のイベントでは初めて会う人が
次に会う人につながっていきます
考えてなかったようなことも
初対面の人と話する
そういうことは 仕事時代では
全然考えることができませんでした
新たな出会いが想像もしなかったような
人やモノにつながっていきます
世界が広がっていきます
そこで 安城市が
健康で幸せなまちづくりを
実現するための企画を
広く市民や企業から募集しておりました
野菜作りグループの会長から
何か提案できるものはないか
という声をかけられ 考えてみました
今までの体験をもとに
自分の想いを被せ イメージしました
畑の中で子どもたちが飛び回って遊んでます
その周りに いろんな家族がつながってます
もう一つ　野菜づくりの人が
商店街の人と談笑しながら
つながっている姿です
そうなんです
人と人とがつながって 新しいコミュニティを
つくっている姿なんです
それを「アグリパーク安城」と名付け
企画提案し 採択されました
そして 活動が始まりました
具体的には 初心者でも楽しめる
農園を開きました
さらに 野菜作りの人が集まって
街の中に野菜市を開き
情報交換の場も設けました
参加する人は 野菜作りの
面白さや感動だけでなくて
私が人とつながって 世界が広がったように
出会った人がつながる
その感覚を持ってほしいと思いました
野菜栽培するだけではなくて
バーベキュー大会で料理をしたり
餅つき大会をやったり
いろいろなイベントを一緒に
作り上げていきました
会員の一人が
「息子は大地と野菜と皆さんのおかげで
育っていきました
ありがとうございました」
その声を聞いたときには
ああ こういう場がつくれたことに
本当に誇りに思いました
また こういう相談を受けたこともあります
若いお母さんです
「子どもに農園をやらせたくて始めました
子どもは全然興味を示さないんですよ
私はもう疲れました
もう辞めたいんです」
お母さんに言いました
「体験させるのは
野菜作りでなくていいんですよ
畑に来て遊ぶだけでいいんですよ
子どもが喜ぶことを一緒になって
探しましょう」と
それからは子どもに
いろいろなことを投げかけました
そのとき 子どもが興味を持った
餅つき大会に参加して
あっという間に友達ができたんですよ
それからというものは
しょっちゅう畑に来て
野菜作りの面倒は見る
友達と遊ぶ
そして 収穫したものの野菜も
しっかり食べるようになったんですよ
お母さんが本当に願ってたのは
同じ想いを持って一緒に過ごす
ということだったんですよ
野菜作りというのは
その願いを叶えるための
一つの目標でしかなかったんですよ
だから 同じ想いを持って一緒に過ごす
その姿を追いかけて 追い求めて
子どもにいろいろなものを提案する中で
子どもは安心して
自分でやれることを見出して
自分から動き出したのです
最初から考えたことに縛られすぎると
あるべき姿を 目指すべき姿を
見失ってしまいます
迷ってしまいます
そういう時は一度立ち止まって
ありたい姿は何なんだろう ということを
もう一度考え直してみる必要が
あるんじゃないでしょうか
こういうふうに ありたい姿を
追いかけていると
面白いことにいろいろな人の
ありたい姿とリンクして
世界が広がってくるんですよ
農園とレストランを一緒にやりたい
子どものスポーツクラブで
野菜栽培をしながら チーム作りをしたい
企業として SDGs的観点から
一つの事業として成り立ちそうだ とか
ありたい姿がくっついてくると
ひとつの素敵な街になりそうです
それは当初掲げたアグリパーク安城という
一つの目標をはるかに超えた
非常にワクワクしたものになります
目標にとらわれず ありたい姿を追いかける
ありたい姿に向かって継続して
たくさんのことをやり遂げる
これが豊かで価値ある人生につながる
鍵になるんではないでしょうか
ありがとうございました
（拍手）